♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE HAVE BEEN
REPORTING ON THE SHOW,
DISTURBING NEW TREND EMERGING,
WHERE PEOPLE ARE DOWSING
NEW YORK CITY POLICE OFFICERS
WITH WATER.
TONIGHT, ANOTHER DISGUSTING,
DESPICABLE VIDEO EMERGES.
RIGHT NOW, HE WAS IN DETROIT.
BY THE WAY, HE SAYS HE MAY COME
ON THIS SHOW.
I HOPE HE DOES.
PEOPLE ARE COMING UP TO SHOW HOW
THEY FEEL ABOUT THEIR MIRROR,
HIS BETRAYAL OF THE FORCE.
THEIR FEELINGS ABOUT THESE
OUTRAGEOUS VIDEOS THAT RESURFAC
RESURFACE.
>> BILL de BLASIO CAN'T RUN
THE CITY, CAN'T RUN THE COUNTRY.
>> MEHR de BLASIO IS THE
CANDIDATE.
IS HE QUALIFIED?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THAT'S A LIE.
HE SHOULD FINISH THE JOB HE RAN
FOR.
HE PROMISED PEOPLE THAT HE WOULD
TAKE CARE OF THEIR PROBLEMS, AND
INSTEAD, HE'S DECIDED TO TAKE
THIS RUN WHEN HE'S LEFT SO MUCH
TO DO IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> HARASSED, ASSAULTED.
>> THE DISORDER IN THIS STREET,
THE DISRESPECT OF POLICE
OFFICERS.
THE ANTIPOLICE RHETORIC.
PEOPLE THINK IT'S SOME SORT OF
GAME TO ATTACK OUR POLICE
OFFICERS, TO THROW WATER ON
THEM.
VIDEO TAPING.
I MEAN, IT'S DISGUSTING.
>> Sean: FOX NEWS
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER AND OUR
CORRESPONDENT.
I WANT TO GET TO BERNIE BERNIE.
THIS IS WHAT I WOULD DO.
I'M NOT THE POLICE COMMISSIONER.
YOU WERE.
YOU WERE ALSO THEY HAD OF
CORRECTIONS AT ONE POINT.
EVERY ONE OF THESE WHO ARE OUT
THERE DISRESPECTING OUR COPS.
I WOULD CHARGE EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THEM WITH ASSAULTING A POLICE
OFFICER, WHICH IS ON    FELONY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, IT SHOULD BE
DONE AT THE SCENE.
CRIMINAL MISCHIEF, ASSAULT.
>> Sean: IS THAT A FELONY, TO
ASSAULT A POLICE OFFICER?
>> THERE ARE OTHER CHARGES, SEAN
HEARD THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
THINGS THE COPS CAN DO.
BUT KEEP IN MIND, THESE COPS
WORK FOR A MAYOR. THEY ARE
AFRAID OF THE MIRROR.
LOOK WHAT HE DID IN THE GARNER
CASE.
HE IS NOT SUPPORTIVE.
>> THE COPS CAN'T DO THEIR JOB.
YOU ARE GOING TO PUT HANDCUFFS
ON COPS, THEY CAN'T DO THEIR JO
JOB.
OH, MY GOSH.
THEY LIED.
YOU HELPED THEM.
WHAT DID THEY TELL YOU TONIGHT?
>> THEY MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
THEY DON'T LIKE THE PLACE.
THE THEY HAVE COMPLETE ANARCHY.
AS A RESULT OF THAT.